In this problem, Romeo and
Juliet are to meet up for a
date, where Romeo arrives at
time x and Juliet at time y,
where x and y are independent
exponential random variables,
with parameters lambda.
And we're interested in knowing
the difference between
the two times of arrivals,
we'll call it z,
written as x minus y.
And we'll like to know what
the distribution of z is,
expressed by the probability
density function, f of z.
Now, we'll do so by using the
so-called convolution formula
that we learn in the lecture.
Recall that if we have a random
variable w that is the
sum of two independent random
variables, x plus y, now, if
that's the case, we can write
the probability [INAUDIBLE]
function, fw, [INAUDIBLE]
as the following integration--
negative infinity to infinity
fx little x times f of y w
minus x, integrated over x.
And to use this expression to
calculate f of z, we need to
do a bit more work.
Notice w is expressed as a sum
of two random variables,
whereas z is expressed as the
subtraction of y from x.
But that's fairly easy to fix.
Now, we can write z.
Instead of a subtraction, write
it as addition of x plus
negative y.
So in the expression of the
convolution formula, we'll
simply replace y by negative
y, as it will
show on the next slide.
Using the convolution formula,
we can write f of z little z
as the integration of f of x
little x and f of negative y z
minus x dx.
Now, we will use the fact that
f of negative y, evaluated z
minus x, is simply equal to f
of y evaluated at x minus z.
To see why this is true, let's
consider, let's say, a
discreet random variable, y.
And now, the probability that
negative y is equal to
negative 1 is simply the same
as probability that
y is equal to 1.
And the same is true for
probability density functions.
With this fact in mind, we can
further write equality as the
integration of x times
f of y x minus z dx.
We're now ready to compute.
We'll first look at the case
where z is less than 0.
On the right, I'm writing out
the distribution of an
exponential random variable
with a parameter lambda.
In this case, using the
integration above, we could
write it as 0 to infinity,
lambda e to the negative
lambda x times lambda e to the
negative lambda x minus z dx.
Now, the reason we chose a
region to integrate from 0 to
positive infinity is because
anywhere else, as we can
verify from the expression of
fx right here, that the
product of fx times
fy here is 0.
Follow this through.
We'll pull out the constant.
Lambda e to the lambda z, the
integral from 0 to infinity,
lambda e to the negative
2 lambda x dx.
This will give us lambda e to
the lambda z minus 1/2 e to
the negative 2 lambda x infinity
minus this expression
value at 0.
And this will give us lamdba
over 2 e to the lambda z.
So now, we have an expression
for f of z evaluated at little
z when little z is
less than 0.
Now that have the distribution
of f of z when z is less than
0, we'd like to know what
happens when z is greater or
equal to 0.
In principle, we can go through
the same procedure of
integration and calculate
that value.
But it turns out, there's
something much simpler.
z is the difference between x
and y, at negative z, simply
the difference between
y and x.
Now, x and y are independent and
identically distributed.
And therefore, x minus
y has the same
distribution as y minus x.
So that tells us z and negative
z have the same
distribution.
What that means is, is the
distribution of z now must be
symmetric around 0.
In other words, if we know that
the shape of f of z below
0 is something like that, then
the shape of it above 0 must
be symmetric.
So here's the origin.
For example, if we were to
evaluate f of z at 1, well,
this will be equal to the value
of f of z at negative 1.
So this will equal to f
of z at negative 1.
Well, with this information in
mind, we know that in general,
f of z little z is equal to
f of z negative little z.
So what this allows us to do is
to get all the information
for z less than 0 and generalize
it to the case
where z is greater
or equal to 0.
In particular, by the symmetry
here, we can write, for the
case z greater or equal to 0,
as lambda over 2 e to the
negative lambda z.
So the negative sign comes
from the fact that the
distribution of f of z is
symmetric around 0.
And simply, we can go back
to the expression
here to get the value.
And all in all, this implies
that f of z little z is equal
to lambda over 2 e to
the negative lambda
absolute value of z.
This completes our problem.